[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
hallweg willkommen an diesem
Freitagabend naubert Lehmann ist auch
dabei für den Sport mit viel Fußball
einen schönen guten Abend auch von mir
schauen wir auf die Nachrichtenthemen
von
heute Überraschung in Hessen die CDU
will nach ihrem klaren Wahlsieg nicht
mehr mit den Grünen sondern lieber mit
der SPD regieren
Landesverteidigung als Ziel der
Verteidigungsminister will die
Bundeswehr kriegstauglich
machen und zurück zur Natur in der EU
soll mindestens ein Fünftel der Land und
Meeresfläche wieder in den
ursprünglichen Zustand versetzt
werden wir beginnen mit dem Paukenschlag
in Hessen der auch in Berlin gehört
wurde statt mit den Grünen weiter zu
regieren wählt Wahlgewinner CDU die SPD
als neuen Partner Ministerpräsident
Boris rin kündigte an
Koalitionsverhandlungen mit den
Sozialdemokraten aufzunehmen seine CDU
war bei der Wahl vor 5 Wochen deutlich
stärkste Kraft geworden vor der AFD der
SPD und den Grünen fast 10 Jahre lang
hatte schwarzgrün in Wiesbaden regiert
warum die CDU jetzt auf die SPD setzt
berichtet Peter
Tyson als Boris rin heute kurz nach 12
Uhr vor die Kameras tritt löst er in
Hessen ein kleines politisches Beben aus
statt wie bisher mit den Grünen will er
eine Koalition mit der SPD klar wir
wollen gemeinsam mit der
Sozialdemokratie in Hessen ein
christlich soziales Programm schreiben
ein Programm das Vernunft und
Fortschritt miteinander verbindet ein
Programm für Vernunft im Umgang mit der
Migration 10 Jahre haben CDU und Grüne
in Hessen geräuschlus zusammen regiert
der frühere Ministerpräsident Volker
bffier und sein viz Tarik alvasir
schätzten und vertrauten sich die Grünen
trugen auch Boris rin als Nachfolger
buffiers mit die Enttäuschung bei ihnen
deutlich
spürbar große Koalitionen gelten
gemeinhin als
Notlösung meistens haben Koalitionen von
CDU und SPD sehr wenige Ergebnisse
weshalb sie eigentlich nur dann
eingegangen werden wenn gar nichts
anderes möglich ist eines ist aber
völlig klar wir können auch Opposition
die häsische SPD Vorsitzende Bundes
Ministerin n fäer betonte dass sie trotz
einer möglichen hässischen CDU SPD
Koalition in Berlin bleiben wird bei den
Sondierungsgesprächen mit der CDU gab es
offenbar große Schnittmengen ja ganz
herzlich Dank das ist ja immer ein
Bündel von tatsächlich in inhaltlichen
Punkten von Bildung über Schaffung von
Wohnraum über die Frage
Industriestandort erhalten Hessen ist
ein starker Industriestandort muss es
aber auch durch den Wandel jetzt bleiben
bei der Landtagswahl hatten sowohl grüne
als auch SPD dramatisch verloren rein
als eindeutiger Wahlsieger konnte sich
seinen Koalitionspartner aussuchen Rhein
betonte heute bei den Wichtigen Themen
innere Sicherheit und Migration sei man
näher bei der
SPD holen wir unsere
hauptstadtkorrespondentin Diana
Zimmermann dazu wie wird die hässische
Entscheidung in Berlin aufgenommen ja
auch die bundesgrünen reagieren
enttäuscht und frustriert völlig
unverständlich sagen sie sei es warum
die hässische CDU ihnen den Rücken
zugekehrt habe die begründet das vor
allem damit dass man in der in Fragen
der Migration nicht zusammengekommen ist
der CDU Parteivorsitzende in Berlin
streut Salz in die offene Wunde die
Grünen müssten an ihrer
Kompromissbereitschaft Arbeiten
Friedrich März hatte sie ja schon im
Sommer als Hauptgegner der Union in der
Ampel ausgemacht und darauf scheint
Boris rin nun einzuschwenken wenn er
heute gleich mehrmals sagte Politik
funktioniere eben über Anreize und nicht
über Verbote die Grünen als
verbotspartei als diejenigen die
angeblich schuld sind wenn die
Einwanderung nach Deutschland nicht
schnell genug begrenzt wird da klatschen
natürlich auch AFD Wähler Beifall und
die zu gewinnen das scheint das Kalkül
zu sein dafür ist es gut die Grünen auf
Distanz zu halten Boris rin handelt aus
Überlegungen für Hessen die SPD ist der
CDU dort näher aber seine Entscheidung
macht auch bundesweit klar schwarzgrün
hat gerade keine Konjunktur und die
geschwächt der SPD ist attraktiv für die
Union als Juniorpartner danke schön für
die diese Einschätzung aus Berlin Diana
Zimmermann war
das die Bundeswehr muss kriegstauglich
werden das wiederholte heute der
Verteidigungsminister er wisse dass das
hart Klinge und einige erschrecke aber
der Krieg sei zurück in Europa und
darauf müsse sich Deutschland einstellen
so Pistorius bei der bundeswehrtagung in
Berlin sein Ziel eine effektive
Abschreckung Kriege führen können um
keinen Krieg führen zu müssen der
Kanzler sichert dafür dauerhaft mehr
Geld zu Ines trums hat
Details viel Gegenwind hat er bekommen
als er im ZDF sagte deutschland müsse
kriegstüchtig werden heute auf der
bundeswehrtagung nutzt
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius das Wort
erneut kriegstüchtigkeit als neue
Handlungsmaxime für die Bundeswehr wir
brauchen eine Bundeswehr die so
aufgestellt und ausgestattet ist dass
Sie uns in einem Krieg verteidigen kann
und dafür muss die Bundeswehr natürlich
ertüchtigt werden nur eine Bundeswehr
die so stark und abschreckend ist also
kriegstüchtig kann am Ende verhindern
dass es zum Äußersten kommt zurück zum
Kerngeschäft zurück zur Landes und
bündnisverteidigung heißt es für die
Bundeswehr in den neuen
verteidigungspolitischen Richtlinien
schließlich rückten Kriege und Konflikte
immer näher entsprechende Reformen
sollen nun mit Tempo vorangetrieben
werden Kanzler Scholz meidet das Wort
kriegstüchtig sagt aber dass wir die
Verteidigungsausgaben dauerhaft auf 2%
heben und diese Zusage gilt sie ist
einer neuen sicherheitspolitischen
Realität geschuldet große Ziele doch
noch sieht die Realität anders aus es
mangelt an Personal die Bewerberzahlen
gehen zurück es fehlt an Gerät die
Beschaffung nach wie vor langsam der
Vertreter der Truppe hat die Botschaft
des Kanzlers zu mehr Geld gehört doch
mag noch nicht daran in wie weit das
durchkommuniziert wird gerade auch in
den Parteien regierungstragenden
Parteien das wird man in den nächsten
Wochen erleben historius will zeigen er
meint es ernst sein Ministerium soll
kleiner und effizienter werden kündigt
er an für die Streitkräfte fordert er
bis Ostern Ideen für eine neue Struktur
zahlreiche Ankündigungen nun gilt es sie
umzusetzen trotz aller Bemühungen und
internationalen Verhandlungen im
Gazastreifen gibt es bislang weder eine
Vereinbarung zu Feuerpausen noch kamen
weitere Geiseln frei die gegenseitigen
Angriffe gehen weiter das Hilfswerk der
Vereinten Nationen für die Palästinenser
teilte mit seit Beginn des Krieges vor 5
Wochen sein auch mehr als 100 un-helfer
getötet worden Henriette
deier Menschen auf der Flucht vom Norden
in den Süden des Gazastreifens es sind
deutlich mehr als in den vergangenen
Wochen es solle stundenweise sichere
Korridore für Zivilisten und
Hilfslieferungen geben sagte israels
Ministerpräsident Benjamin netanahu
gestern im
usfernsehen es wird keinen
Waffenstillstand geben solange die
israelischen Geiseln nicht freigelassen
werden aber wir haben
sicherheitskorridoren
zugestimmt Bilder des israelischen
Militärs sollen ein un Hilfskonvoi
zeigen der einen solchen
sicherheitskorridor nutzt die Vereinten
Nationen kritisieren die kurzen
Feuerpausen seinen zynisch und
grausam wenn wir ehrlich sind ist das
ein Tropfen auf den heißen Stein es wird
so viel gebraucht um den Zivilisten im
gaserastreifen zu helfen dazu brauchen
wir einen humanitären
Waffenstillstand denn die humanitäre
Lage der Menschen im Gazastreifen spitzt
sich immer weiter zu auch in diesem
flüchtlingskcamp plötzlich war hier
alles überfüllt inzwischen leben
mindestens5 Menschen hier die
Hilfsorganisation kommt nicht hinterher
das Minimum an Nahrungsmitteln Wasser
und Medikamenten bereitzustellen
Grundbedürfnisse der Vertriebenen um den
Mindeststandard ans menschliche Leben zu
gewährleisten das israelische Militär
veröffentlicht heute diese Bilder sie
sollen zeigen dass die Truppen auch
heute weiter vorgedrungen
sind golineai in Kairo freitags zeigt
sich auf der Protest in der arabischen
Welt heute war vergleichsweise wenig los
was lässt sich daraus
ablesen ja Proteste hat es heute hier
nur sehr vereinzelt gegeben im Oman in
Jordanien im Jemen ansonsten blieb es
aber bemerkenswert still und das hat
verschiedene Gründe zum einen ist es so
dass hier z.B in Ägypten viele nicht
wegen eines aktuellen Hamas
protestaufrufs auf die Straße gehen
sondern die meisten gehen in erster
Linie auf die Straße um ihre Solidarität
mit den ensern auszudrücken und zum
anderen ist es so dass viele Proteste
hier in der Region unterdrückt werden
denn viele autokratische Herrscher in
der Region befürchten dass sich der
Einsatz für Palästina auf der Straße
vermischt mit anderen Anliegen z.B
Proteste für die Freiheit Proteste für
mehr soziale Gerechtigkeit und so kommt
es dann auch dazu dass der die Wut auf
der Straße aktuell sich in anderen
Protestformen kanalisiert z.B recht
erfolgreiche Boykott Aufrufe gegen
westliche Produkte keine Demonstration
auf der Straße das bedeutet nicht dass
es keine Wut gibt gegen die westliche
israelptik im Gegenteil dass der Westen
sich nicht dazu entschließen kann einen
eindeutigen Waffenstillstand in Gaza zu
fordern das Empfinden sehr viele hier
als großes moralisches Versagen als
großes moralisches Scheitern der Graben
zwischen den Welten er könnte nicht
größer sein als im Moment danke schön
nach Kairo golini atai
das Leid von unschuldigen Kindern Frauen
und mänern lindern mit diesem Ziel ist
bundesaußenministerin Anna Lena bärbock
zu einer weiteren vermittlungsreise in
den Nahen Osten aufgebrochen ihre erste
Station die Vereinigten Arabischen
Emirate dort hat sie soeben mit ihrem
Amtskollegen beraten in den Gesprächen
dürfte es auch um die Befreiung der
hamasgeiseln gehen unter denen sich noch
mehrere deutsche befinden noch am Abend
wird bärbock nach Saudi Arabien
weiterreisen und morgen nach
Israel und jetzt ist anche pieer hier
mit im Studio mit den neuesten Zahlen
vom Politbarometer auch zum Thema nost
guten Abend anche wie sehen die
Befragten die Angriffe Israels im
Gazastreifen ja viele sehen die
Erfolgsaussichten skeptisch fast zwei
Drittel glauben nicht dass es Israel
gelingen wird die Hamas so stark zu
schwächen dass von ihr keine Gefahr mehr
für Israel ausgeht das Militär Vorgehen
Israels im Gazastreifen für
gerechtfertigt hält die Hälfte der
Befragten 35% sehen das nicht so
85 Jahre nach der
reispurromnacht haben wir auch nach
Antisemitismus in Deutschland gefragt
mehr als die Hälfte der Befragten im ZDF
Politbarometer sagen dass die
Judenfeindlichkeit hier zu Lande groß
oder sehr groß ist lass uns noch über
einen anderen Punkt reden Sarah
Wagenknecht sie hat die Linke verlassen
und will jetzt mit neuer Partei loslegen
wie sehen ihre Chancen aus ja ihre
startschancen sind ganz gut 13% wollen
die angekündigte wagenknechtpartei bei
der nächsten Bundestagswahl
wahrscheinlich oder sogar sicher wählen
vor allem übrigens bisherige Anhänger
der Linkspartei und der AFD aber das ist
Zukunftsmusik wenn bereits am Sonntag
Bundestagswahl wäre gäb es wenig
Veränderung gegenüber der letzten
Umfrage die SPD käme auf 16% + 1 CDU CSU
unverändert auf 30 die Grünen 15 + 1 FDP
5% AFD wieder 21 die Linke nur noch 4-1
und die Freien Wähler kämen auf
3% immer wieder interessant danke schön
anche pieer alle Zahlen vom
Politbarometer gibt's im heute journal
um 22 Uhr oder jederzeit online auf
heute.de und auch bei Whatsapp einfach
unseren ZDF heute Kanal abonnieren wie
das finden Sie in der an itung auf
unserer Homepage ZDF heute und in
unserer
App international tätige Großunternehmen
sollen künftig weltweit eine
Mindeststeuer von 15% Zahlen der
Bundestag hat heute für die Umsetzung
einer entsprechenden Richtlinie in
nationales Recht gestimmt die Reform
soll verhindern dass Großkonzerne ihre
Gewinne in Länder Verschieben in denen
sie weniger Steuern zahlen müssen das
Finanzministerium rechnet dadurch 2026
mit mehr Einnahmen von mehr als 900
Millionen Euro und noch ein Beschluss
des Bundestags die Abgeordneten haben
die staatliche Finanzierung parteier
Stiftungen geregelt eine Voraussetzung
nur Stiftungen der Parteien bekommen
Geld die mindestens drei Wahlperioden
lang im Bundestag vertreten sind dagegen
hat die AFD vehement protestiert weil
sie noch nicht so lange dabei ist die
ihr nahestehende Stiftung wird nun nicht
gefördert in Polen hat das siegreiche
Oppositionsbündnis knapp vier Wochen
nach der Parlamentswahl die Bildung
einer Koalition vereinbart unter der
Führung des ehemaligen
EU-Ratspräsidenten Tusk hatte die
liberalkonservative bürgerkoalition bei
der Wahl eine deutliche Mehrheit
errungen die nationalkonservative
Regierungspartei PIs hatte zwar die
meisten Stimmen erhalten findet aber
keinen
Koalitionspartner
in Spanien kann der sozialistische
Ministerpräsident Sanchez
voraussichtlich weiter regieren er hat
mit der baskischen Partei einen weiteren
Bündnispartner gefunden und damit eine
Regierungsmehrheit erreicht erst gestern
hatten tausende gegen die angekündigte
Begnadigung von 1400 Verurteilten
Separatisten protestiert die Amnestie
ist Bestandteil eines Deals mit der
katalanischen Partei die Sanchez
ebenfalls für sein Sechser Bündnis
braucht
eines der ehrgeizigsten Umweltprojekte
der EU hat vergangene Nacht eine
wichtige Hürde genommen das Parlament
und die EU-Staaten einigten sich nach
langem Streit auf das Gesetz zur
Wiederherstellung der Natur damit sollen
in Europa mehr Wälder aufgeforstet mohre
gerettet und Flüsse renaturiert werden
denn laut eu-daten sind 80% der
in einem schleten Zustand Florian neuh
berichtet ein Mo in Niedersachsen nass
und unglaublich wichtig für Klima und
Natur das Problem ein Großteil solcher
more in Europa wurde längst trocken
gelegt jetzt will die EU hier
gegensteuern mit einem europäischen
Naturschutzgesetz gestern letzte
Verhandlung zwischen Rat der
Mitgliedstaaten und Parlament in der
Nacht vermelden beide die
Einigung istste gesha die Natur nicht
nur schützt sondern sie auch
wiederherstellen
soll kaum ein Brüsseler Vorhaben war so
umstritten wie dieses wurde nicht nur
von Landwirten bekämpft aus Sorge vor zu
hohen Auflagen laut Einigung soll bis
2030 auf 20% der Fläche von Wäldern bis
mohen die Natur wiederhergestellt werden
welche Maßnahmen die Staaten dafür genau
ergreifen lässt man offen für Landwirte
aber gibt es keine Verpflichtung mehr
Flächen zuen für diese Ausnahme hatten
sich vor allem die Christdemokraten im
EU-Parlament eingesetzt wir diskutieren
ganz viel über das Thema
Ernährungssicherheit dann kann ich nicht
immer mehr landwirtschaftliche
Produktion landwirtschaftliche
Nutzfläche zurückfahren die Grünen
hätten die Landwirtschaft gern
verpflichtet finden den Kompromiss aber
besser als gar kein Gesetz wenn wir die
Natur immer weiter zurückdrengen
gefährden wir unsere eigenen
überlebensgrundlagen und deshalb ist
dieses Gesetz so elementar deutschen
geht auch die aktuelle Einigung zu weit
man brauche finanzielle Anreize statt
starre Ziele das Gesetz muss jetzt noch
vom EU-Parlament bestätigt werden
normalerweise Formsache diesmal aber ist
offen ob ausreichend konservative
zustimmen
werden und jetzt Fußball das war ein aus
deutscher Sicht erfolgreicher Abend in
der Europa und conference League ja kann
man wohl sagen drei Siege fangen wir mit
den Freiburgern an die feierten daheim
ein wahres Schützenfest 5:0 gegen den
Club BKA Topa der SC mit besten Chancen
aus Europa League
Achtelfinale 5 mit einem Streich beim
persönlichen
europapokalrekordsieg mit einem GAL
auftritt und F Torschützen trotzdem
bleibt Streich wie er ist bodenständig
die junge muss einfach jetzt
schauen dass man die Kirche im Dorf
lassen dass sie in Ruhe Arbeit Kön
Freiburg in rot taktisch klugestell
serbischen Vizemeister topoller im
Gegensatz zum 3:3 gegen Gladbach das 1:0
durch Röhl zum Halbzeitstand das 3:0
durch Weißhaupt jetzt heißt regenerieren
ausruhe hab nicht lang Zeit aber so
viele Spiele den Schwung gibt es
mitzunehmen die Bundesliga ist kein
Wunschkonzert nicht für einen Christian
Streich nicht auswärts in
Leipzig ja und auch für Leverkusen ist
das Europa League Achtelfinale zum
Greifen nah nach dem 1:0 Sieg bei
Karabach agdam die Entscheidung in Baku
fiel erst in der Nachspielzeit Victor
Boniface verwandelte sicher einen
Handelfmeter und in der Conference
League hat Frankfurt durch das 1:0 in
Helsinki bereits die Kunde erreicht
Bundestrainer julian nagelsmann hat
einen Neuling ins dfbteam Berufen Bremen
Stör war Marvin duxch der früher bei
Werder zusammen mit Nationalspieler
Niklas hülkru vorne für für Wirbel
gesorgt hatte für Marvin duxch geht ein
Traum in Erfüllung aber mit 32 Toren aus
63 Bundesliga spielen hat er sich
durchaus empfohlen er ist einer der
frech nach vorne spielt der 29-Jährige
der seit 2021 für Werder Bremen kickt
ist dort bekannt als der Mann mit dem
gewissen Instinkt duch ist nach der
mialer Verletzung im Champions League
Spiel gegen galatasarai eine Option im
Angriff für Bundestrainer Julian
nagelsmann und vielleicht gibt es ja
eine Wiedervereinigung mit seinem ehemal
Werder Sturmpartner Niklas
fükuck erste Gelegenheit dazu am 18.11
im Testspiel gegen die Türkei ich danke
bitte und jetzt stellen wir Ihnen noch
jemanden vor der eigentlich äußerst
kamerascheu ist der
attenboro
langschnabeligel die Art galt als
ausgestorben jetzt wurde der Igel in
Indonesien von einer kamerafalle
aufgenommen das scheue Tier hat die
Stacheln eines Igels die Schnauze eines
ameisenbärs die Füße eines Maulwurfs und
es kann Eier legen benannt ist es nach
dem legendären britischen Tierfilmer
David
attenborrow das Wochenende wird nicht
überall trüb es wird wechselhaft mit
Schnee in den Bergen zwischenendurch
gibt's aber auch mal Sonne Details hat
gleich Katja hornffer Maria taslomka
begrüßt sie um 22 Uhr im heute journal
und wir alle von der heute Crew wünschen
Ihnen ein schönes Wochenende bis morgen
wenn Sie mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend zum Wochenende beruhigt sich
das Wetter und das liegt an diesem
kleinen Zwischenhoch das morgen über
Frankreich bis nach Süddeutschland zieht
heute Nacht allerdings fällt noch Regen
und es könnte auch noch mal einzelnes
Gewitter dabei sein eher trocken bleibt
es ganz im Norden und ganz im Osten die
Temperaturen sinken am Alpenrand bis -1°
und so fällt oberhalb von 700 bis 1000 m
auch Schnee in der Nacht da im Süden
deutlich milder bleibt die Nacht hier im
Nordwesten mit 6° und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen bei 4° an den Alpen
bei 10° am Rhein oder an der Nordsee der
Vormittag ist meist noch drüben es fällt
Regen in den Mittelgebirgen und am
Alpenrand ist auch oberhalb von 700 bis
1000 m Schnee dabei freundlicher ist es
noch hier im Nordosten und hinter dem
Regen lockern die Wolken im Südwesten
schon wieder auf und dieser freundliche
Bereich wird sich am Nachmittag weiter
nach Osten ausweiten dafür verschwindet
die Sonne im Nordosten mehr und mehr der
Wind da zuu kommt meist aus westlichen
Richtungen der Sonntag wird insgesamt
etwas ruhiger da kann es noch mal einen
kleinen Regenschauer in Brandenburg
geben und schneeregenfälle im
Schwarzwald und am Alpenrand an den
Temperaturen ändert sich wenig die
liegen zwischen 4 und 10° guten
Abend